i want to thank the the uh
former general i keep calling him
general my
my uh the guy who runs that outfit over
there
uh i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done well that
obviously president joe biden at a
ceremony uh
talking about his defense secretary
right behind him uh and
his critics pointing that he didn't
remember his name in that
that uh statement we're back with our
interview with west virginia democratic
senator joe manchin you know
senator some of his critics the
president's critics say he's lost a step
or two or more um there are
even allies who are concerned that he
hasn't had a press conference
in the time he's been in office you've
worked with him you've been with him
what do you think about president biden
and are you concerned about any of that
well the time that i've spoken to him
and been with him he hasn't missed the
step
he's very straightforward and we talk
and have very
very direct talks and i know exactly
where he's coming from he knows where
i'm coming from and
the thing i appreciate most he says joe
he says
i never asked you to go against your
convictions and i said
mr president i appreciate that because i
wouldn't so we've had good conversations
and those things that we agree and
things that we disagree
i think the keystone pipeline he knows i
support that wholeheartedly i think we
have to have the safest
means of transporting the energy i'm all
in for an all-in energy policy
so we have things to work through we'll
see how that comes out they're talking
about a lot of big things infrastructure
i'm all for infrastructure but we're
gonna have to figure out how we're gonna
pay for this
yeah you're not worried that he hasn't
had a solo press conference
i really am not you know as far as
forgetting a person's name i've done
that before too and
i hope they haven't thought i've lost it
too but
and brett you'll get there buddy you'll
get all right senator i want to ask you
about nominations you were against
near a tendon to be president biden's
omb director in part because of her
her tweets do you plan to vote in the
same way because of the tweets from the
president's pick to lead the policy
division at the pentagon dr colin uh
call
well i've seen some tweets and they are
concerning and i've talked to him
about those uh and he's uh he's well
experienced and well accomplished in
that
in in
confirm him to and we spoke about all
those things
first of all his tweeting is nowhere
near uh
what uh near tanden's was and
we spoke about that too and i just said
january 6 changed me i said when you
have someone that's just prolific about
this
and i understand basically the tweet
that and i felt the same that he might
have felt we talked about
uh when the kurds our uh our syrian
kurds
were left at the hands of erdogan and
turkey
we were concerned about that well i bit
my tongue and i said where i could in
private
how i felt about it you didn't you know
and he just basically
said it and it was ill-advised and he
apologized for that so
sounds like you're going to vote for him
i mean there's a couple things in here
he calls republicans a death cult
he says the blood of the hands of yemen
is on the republicans
says me specifically about specific
senators brett i've reached out to
republicans who he's worked with
and who he's worked under i want to get
everybody's input so i'm gathering all
that information
i have not made a final decision has the
defense secretary called you
pardon me has defense secretary austin
lobbied you or called you about
we've spoken we have spoken i have the
utmost respect for general
austin now secretary lloyd austin and
i've spoken to bob gates
former secretary these are good people
and
you want to get all the input you can i
want to know the demeanor of that person
i want another temperance
of that person i want to get the feel of
who that person is
last thing do you see
a next step a bipartisan piece of
legislation
that is coming down the pike as you look
at
and talking to the administration
anything
bipartisan well i can tell you one thing
brett i've been saying this for a long
time
infrastructure should be one that brings
us all together
we all have crumbling roads and bridges
and we have water lines and sewer lines
we all have needs and we have deferred
maintenance has been let go for far
too long if that doesn't bring us
together we're in serious problems
if that one infrastructure bill can't
unite our country and say you know what
that bridge over there is not a
republican or democrat bridge that's my
bridge and it's going to fall in if we
don't fix it
there's things we've got to do to build
america up and i'm hoping that's that's
the one thing that brings us together
we'll find out you know there are people
out there who looked at that image
of the 10 gop senators in the oval
office with president biden and they
felt hopeful that this was going to be
the beginning of a negotiation
on the coveted relief package that did
not happen there wasn't even an
offer to get gop efforts
involved there as far as going back and
forth what the number is going to be so
how can you look at infrastructure and
say well this is going to be different
when coveted relief is a big deal for
republicans too well brett here was the
thing basically and i spoke to president
biden about that and he says joe he says
i tried to work for his affordable care
act back in 2009
and he thought that they could really
work with republicans they were
negotiating for six or eight months and
then it fell apart at the end
he says we can't wait six or eight
months on the coveted relief that we
need
now i wanted to do a coveted relief i
thought the right thing to do
let's vote on vaccines let's vote on
unemployment the things that are
necessary
whether it's three four five hundred
billion on the front end and then if
they needed to go to reconciliation
because of the coveted recovery that
would have been fine
too but it just wasn't wasn't to work
that way and you know i just i
was very honest with my opinion and with
that i had to look at the overall
objective of what we were trying to
accomplish not for the immediate
but also for the future and i think this
bill will do that
okay senator joe manchin always good to
have you
on the program thanks brett good to be
with you